مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره افاد
مراسل الجزيره في القدس لان الاسرائيليين
قتل وجرح ال 10 في تفجيرين متزامنين داخل
محطتين للحافلات في القدس الغربيه وقالت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه ان شخصا وضع المتفجرات
داخل حقيبه في المحطتين وان نحتقبتين
فجرتان عن بعد وقد رفعت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه المستوى التاهب في المدينه
ومحيطها بعد تفجيرين الذين
يعداني اول عمليه من نوعها في القدس منذ
وفاه الممثلين رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي قرر اختصار زيارته الى واشنطن
والعوده بعد تفجيرين بجانبه طلب اتمار بن
كثير المرشح الاقوى لتولي حقيبه الامن
الداخلي في حكومه نتنياهو الجديده باجتياح
الضفه الغربيه
قال الجيش الاوكراني ان الدفاعات الجويه
اسقطته 51 صاروخا روسيه من اصله 70
استهدفت البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في البلاد
واضاف الجيش ان القصر ادى الى انقطاع
الطاقه عن ثلاث محطات لطاقه النوويه
وانقطاع الكهرباء والماء عن كيف ومدن اخرى
هذا عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه طارئه
لبحث في تطورات في اوكرانيا واتهمت
المندوبه الامريكيه في كلمتها امام الجلسه
الرئيس الروسي باستخدام فصل الشتاء كسلاحا
معتبره ان روسيا تتبع واستراتيجيه جبانه
وغير انسانيه في المقابل قال مندوب روسيا
بمجلس الامن ان الضربات الروسيه الدقيقه
وتستهدف البنيه التحتيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
وقد نجد البيت الابيض بضربات الروسيه على
المدن الاوكرانيه معتبرا بانها تهدف فقط
الى زياده معاناه الاوكرانيين وليس لها اي
هدف عسكري اضاف البيت الابيض في بيان له
ان الرؤيه تبدا مستعده زياده مخاطر وقوع
حادثه النوويه من شانه اي يلحق الضرر
بالمنطقه باكملها
نفى المتحدث باسم الكرملين وجود اي
مفاوضات حاليا مع الولايات المتحده بشان
اوكرانيا
العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
اكد الرئيس
ان بلادهم مصممه على التحرك لتامين حدودها
الجنوبيه مع سوريا
في شمال سوريا
وقال مبعوث هو الرئيس الروسي سوريا
[موسيقى]